Tu sais Valérie
T'es la femme de ma vie
je le sais, je le sent
Mais, tu n'as pas besoin
de courir le monde après ton destin
comme un cheval sauvage
ni comme une belette sauvage d'ailleurs
ou un chevreuil
ou un furet à tête de tigre
ou un renard
ou un épagneule breton
ou un koala
ou un poney châtelain
ou une perdrix en période de brame
ou une gerbille
Oui ! Ou un chevreuil
Ou une murène
ou un chevreuil
Hey ! ça va mec, tranquille on ne te déranges pas !
Pardon excuse moi je me suis un peu ...
ou un chevreuil
ou un hiboux
ou une couleuvre
ou un chevreuil
ou un coléoptère
excusez-moi deux petites secondes en fait j'ai envie de faire un tout petit pipi donc j'y vais, bisous Zoé... Hou t'es mouillé. Allez tchao !
ou un chevreuil